[Music]
in celebrity threesome news submitted by
friends dude they just paid a hundred
million dollars to keep that [ __ ] on
that flip [ __ ] million flexpay two
hundred million yeah cuz they have to
pay the Rights of God can you imagine
being on a show where it's like you find
out like ten years or whatever the
fifteen years since the show it's like
hey you guys are splitting a hundred
million anyways happy happy crystal also
so that's why Netflix gets rid of show
sometimes because they only pay for the
rights were cinema all the Disney stuff
is leaving what did you think that I
thought they were just real like you
know what we're just gonna have this for
a little bit of time to make it like you
know SLUSA I only have a certain time to
watch like naturally branch it and then
it's long cast members still makes seven
figures a year just off reruns and [ __ ]
70 cases syndication bro that's what the
[ __ ] is up that's what everyone wants
five seasons on a TV show yeah a man I
get residual while in are checks for
like three dollars
you know I'd be cracking up with my
friends like they always all the actors
they posted residuals as a joke they're
like ballin 12 cents 30 cents every once
in a while I get a stack of like 20
checks from wildin out 20 cents 30 cents
no fifty dollars like a class-action
lawsuit he who's doing all the
accounting for all this [ __ ] dude the
people who are sad people may take
something as a writer that's the [ __ ]
like owning a piece of it like being an
exec producer and [ __ ] cuz as a talent
you get the most [ __ ] but then if you
get if you have a percentage like
sometimes I get sick checks out of
nowhere and it's like what's that like
20 grand
that's say out of nowhere I don't even
know I'm like wait what dear my gram how
mobile you're John be cute on campus I'm
gonna write that's what's up Steve just
weird flexing hey you you asked me to I
wasn't gonna say anything no I need to
know on the production comes yeah buddy
yeah cuz I'm like wait twenty grand
that's Bitcoin money baby Mickey's at
her house right now just [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's like that's great we have a good
time
oh my god jennifer aniston says she
finds it flattering that Dolly Parton's
husband wants a threesome with her
alright hold that man has a weird flash
all the way we're Jennifer Aniston so
Dolly Parton's husband yeah once a
threesome with his wife him and Jennifer
Aniston why is that so shocking to her
because a lot of men walk did she like
well I'll pass my prime so it's shocking
I think it's shocking because they work
together on a show Oh shouting oh
there's like a whole thing here look
here to check it out throw me a piece
you know didn't look like she passed
away okay you know I love her to death
my husband it's crazy about her I was
gonna do a movie with her then who was
it that I got a chance to write all this
music I think he kind of fantasizes like
a threesome
[Laughter]
there we go Hey roasted funny
my favorite got hurt from that one dude
a good woman has to roast her man yeah
first of all Dolly Parton could get it
still absolutely how is she like a
hundred and two looking like that still
looking like she's 92 she was a little
Margie a little bit averey yeah you're
right in a hotter way than even I woulda
man like tapped her forehead with a tiny
hammer it would shatter her face and
there's something else would you like
mushrooms stamped her for ya yeah she's
like a wrinkled Elvira
sexy you [ __ ] to pastor's wife there
dude Frances or the [ __ ] so it'd be like
this right and then plus add that equals
but then you have to remember she looks
like she was like this now ma'am
look if Dolly Parton came up to me and
my chick and my chick was down and
that's important one a threesome I would
be all the way in you would do it for
the story cuz all you're saying and
because I would like to also have sex
with Dolly Parton yeah I don't disagree
with you you're open-minded you wouldn't
I don't like chicks that are over 65
soft eighties though yeah and the real
weight those are real they gotta be
there's no way those I thought those are
I thought her whole face is like plastic
to know I mean her face is dev Lena
titties or hers
yeah that's why she's Fae manners no
they're not
not anymore not anymore okay it's not
why she's famous but it's like that's
like she's had that seems to be gimmick
right when were implants weren't that
popular so I don't know if it was
implants or Reno they gotta be implants
this is what I think they were real at
first but as she got older she replaced
them and that's what it is it's possible
or maybe they're just you know reshaping
and [ __ ] I think they're real no way bro
I'm gonna look this [ __ ] up this [ __ ]
gotta know now there's no way that's
real I think I don't know if I I think I
get limp if I saw her naked me too as
you know you never know that's it yeah
you haven't seen old ladies no yeah yeah
well you know what you're thinking about
is being on a porn set with like [ __ ]
300 lights I'm talking about in the dark
over the bag right and if any light
comes on like even if a [ __ ] car cuz
like sweeping by loves your eyes or no I
take off a shoe and I [ __ ] throw it
at the window but naked old ladies have
bony asses and they have steak bread
wait what she's a celebrity those are
different good you guys are very open ml
to their skin old people you could smell
history on that 1950s New York doesn't
think so so the [ __ ] would not be that
fun probably I mean but I don't know I
haven't heard she probably smells like
Grandma perfume but also she's famous I
feel like famous people got different
things they do to keep this [ __ ] just
you know everything she's like you know
they're immortal yes that's true she got
that [ __ ] southern bedtime story
voice too like you don't like that maybe
because I want to hear that I picked her
lady churning butter yeah okay it makes
me probably get a pie Dolly Parton's
even said they're fake bro okay well
either way they're sweet you think this
shit's real you [ __ ] idiot
put your bras D yeah I don't know
there's girls with really big panties
there are some Japanese pornos that
specifically specialize in big titty
[ __ ] it's a genre are we talking
about the mean real yeah they're real
okay yeah big naturals you're talking
that that's not big titty [ __ ] big
naturals okay you're gonna get the
category right I was like wait a minute
we're not [ __ ] are we exactly I'm on the
site with you but am I gonna make you
could tell the difference [ __ ]
you know you could tell the difference
because when they take off the bra it
sags like a [ __ ] grocery bag of water
but I feel like but I'm not mad at that
though you feel me cuz that's how you
yeah that's like it's a wonderful looks
natural it's beautiful you don't say
like what about the wrinkles and stuff
in the baby so the bad calls veins we
saw some old lady said it yes or no what
about fake titties no words like they
take off the bra and then nothing even
move they levitate [ __ ] move it just
stays stiff it's fresh I think it stays
there but then the older it gets the to
drop you know it also depends on if the
work yeah what kind of work they had
done that I'm saying like is that
Beverly Hills or people Rivero work
right if you want to get faked is a
menace on you like you know hey if that
makes you happy that's cool but like
definitely sometimes it's it throws you
off when the bra comes off and they
don't like move at all you know I'm
saying yeah it's pretty interesting it's
freshly made because there's different
kinds of implants to like you ever heard
of the gummies like the gummies are more
expensive but them shits are like water
balloons you know I'm saying really as
opposed to like what's gummies though so
there's a special implants called the
gummy implant and it's made of a
different material than like the
silicone implants yeah like the mousepad
should yeah yeah yeah so these things
are like they're interesting brought out
a home girl way back and she it was the
old because she had a little bit of like
fat already you know I was a fat around
the gummy
and them shits felt like real I could
not tell they were fake titties it was
crazy
that's of me yeah Wow she was a real
keeper you really [ __ ] about oh that's
just a friend
Oh Brendan you're like hey real quick
let me just and she's like well you
never had like a home girl with like
fake cities because they're so eager to
let people like touch on stuff laughs
yeah girls effects you guys are like oh
nothing guys because I can't feel it
yeah yeah I can't tell the difference be
true some like some fake fake Nate like
oh man I don't know hard hard once like
literally when they take this [ __ ] off
it's just like it doesn't move and
there's like cows as I felt real titties
that are hard yeah there's some strong
women dude are you sure yeah titties it
was really yeah it was in a Catholic no
like in the gym Nate in the gin hall
like a gymnastics girl doesn't like
muscle I mean it's not like rock-hard
like a brick but it was like what the
[ __ ] is this
yeah you sure does more thing you sure
she didn't have breast cancer like some
cities are definitely ones you could
like squish all the like you can you can
touch your hand they're so soft right
other ones aren't like the other ones
are firmer is not even muscles they're
just kind of like that super firm where
it felt like there's no fat yeah I hate
when you squeeze the titty and then it
kind of falls all over the back of your
hand like it's a lot of blue your big
mozzarella meeting don't wreck no girl
whose nipples were so long he said they
would they would hang I've seen that
[ __ ] dude so it's like you're sucking
the kids dick
no thank you it's like when you get a
balloon and you don't [ __ ] blow it up
all the way and just like it's that last
yeah yeah it's like that lady we've all
seen that picture that lady who can make
her eyes pop out of her [ __ ] oh yeah
but those are nipples I'm like mmm evil
witch's nose that's what it looks yeah
it's crazy how a value of a human being
is highly determined by the size of
their tips well dude they've done
studies where if you have bigger boobs
you can get more tips and people treat
you nice it's crazy
dogs I know cuz men are trash that's why
I brought a trash well what is it though
about a gut like if I'm getting a cup of
coffee because that's all that's on
Mythbusters where this chick they like
pad the [ __ ] out of her boobs and they
look pretty dope and then she's like
standing there and then they had to run
a coffee store she's like a barista you
know what and then you guys were giving
tips to her big because the guy is
saying thank you for existing and
allowing me to look I think that guys
are sweet are so territorial in a weird
like primal way now we're like maybe in
the future I will breed with you
that's pilot for sure I I agree with
that I feel like even if I'm too cheap
even if it's not like I straight up hey
um I think you want to have sex with me
so here's a bunch of money I think it's
like I'm gonna leave a good impression
on this person yeah and I'm gonna
remember me and maybe in the future she
might be down for hang out and
canoodling [ __ ] maybe she sees me slip
two dollars in here right now should
kind of I [ __ ] me and I'll be like later
it's like yes I can't take care of our
future children that's what they're
saying
what do dollars yeah one shoulder touch
I'm [ __ ] poor this was gonna happen
oh yeah well I shot he was like did you
enjoy your meal well why don't you ask
some more questions than I cuz at Panda
Express good they're ranked in my diet
and I'm at this I'm at the register and
this girl who I would describe as cute
she guys do I want to donate $1 to
Children's Hospital some [ __ ] I'm like
yes I didn't know if that gives money to
the charity or nothing but I was like
cuz you don't want to go the rest of
your life thinking that some hot chick
was like some this [ __ ] guy would
not even give a dollar to go bout hair
get goofy face with bad hair
I was gonna have sex with that guy or at
least maybe sometime in the future
donations ourselves a dishonest justice
right now we're [ __ ] terrible men are
trapped
we are trash
[Music]